HE'S NOT THE BIGGEST.
HE CAN MOVE THE PUCK.
HE'S GOT TO CLEAN UP HIS RYAN GT
PAST THE DEFENSEMAN.
HE HAD MOMENTUM AND SPEED, GETS.
>> Steve: THE PANDEMIC.AHEAD.
TOMAS TATAR WITH
PLAY, HUNTING THE PU NEW
JERSEY TODAY.
PUCK TAKEN TRY.
O'REILLY ON THE PUCK, DROPS IT
BACK, JUSTIN FAULK SHOOTING AND
DEEPER.
DEVILS ARE OUTSHOOTING
THE DEFENSEMAN WAS NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO PICK>> Steve: BIG MA.
TY SMITH SHOOTS ANDCHIER BACKS .
.
THE FOLLOWING
>> Ken: LET'S LOO CHANCE FROM TE
BY BRAYDEN SCHENNNNUCK OVER LIKE
A SECOND AND A HAL ROCKETRY CHA
SLOT SHOT.
CONTINUING, YOU KNOW, MAKING --
ST. LOUIS MAKING GREAT DECISIONS
WITH THE
THAT'S JUST GREAT VISION BY
BACK-CHECKING O'REILLY.
PLAYS IT
HUGHES ACROSS FOR GRAVES.RY, YE.
YOU'RE NOT BETTING AGAINST HIM
BY ANYSCORES.
TO SEND TOWARDS GOAL. THE
BACK THE OTHHERE.
THROUGH THE NEUTRAL ZONE,
NOBODY'S ABLE TO FILL THOSE
LANES.
OVER THE LINE.
RISER
HIS SHOTS VERYYBRATT.
SUPPORT FOR HAMILTON.
SPINS AWAY FROM FAULK, DROPS ON.
BACK TO KRUG.
CAST
SEIGENTHALER ABLE  DOING A GOOD
JOB FOR T
HUSSO IS OUT THERE SET PLAY.
SHOT, CANG.
THE DEVILS HAVE BEEN FUN AND
EXCITING TO WATCH IN OVOV